didn't file my taxes for 2020 and 2021 U
probably 80% of that was um obviously
commission so I did Dum uh I know I need
to file those now obviously and I'm GNA
owe quite a bit I was just going to see
if I can maybe get some um advice on how
to go about doing that in the the least
harmful way ouch okay here here's the
thing not paying taxes is not a criminal
act not filing taxes is a criminal act
that's what's weird we do not have a
debtor's prison they don't put people in
jail for not paying their taxes but they
do put people in jail about 2500 a year
for failure to file okay so that's where
that's the danger that you're in I'm
more concerned about that than I am the
payment plan I don't think you're in
trouble and because 99% of the time that
you're not some Pol not some public
figure that you come and self F you know
you catch up your filings they're just
all late um you don't get into any
criminal issues